For this program assignment, you need to create the variable year_joined,
and assign it to the data frame pf. To do that,
we just need to take our reference year 2014, and subtract
off our tenure, or the number of days someone's been active
on Facebook. Now, tenure is measured in days rather than in
years, so we need to divide this 365. I also need
to make sure that I actually access the variable so I
need to include pf right here with a dollar sign. Now,
this number will give me a year with a little
bit of extra if there's a decimal. Now, I don't really
care about the decimal, since that doesn't make a full
year, so I just want to floor this number. The function
floor will return the greatest integer that's not larger than
this number. When I run the code, it doesn't look like
much happened. But if I check my data frame, I
can see that I have another variable. There it is, year_joined.